All right. So, any other question? I'm
going to send you the link right here.
Private chat. Okay. Uh, I think I had
one more. Uh, it was more in the
understanding of getting into reading at
least two pages a day at this guy. And I
didn't quite understand when they were
giving an explanation for why um like
the line of Adam to Noah why they were
so old or why they use those numbers.
They had given like a couple of reasons
as to like they think it's because of
the tribes or it's because of You mean
how old? live. Yeah. Like is Adam lived
to be 900 something and then he very
common sense. Can I can I show you
common sense? Why? Yeah. Okay. When God
created humanity, did he create them to
die or to live forever?
To live forever originally before sin.
Okay. Number one. Number two, why did
corruption, decay take place? Because of
sin. Right. Yeah. Now, do you
think when these people live closer to
the time of creation, the natural forces
and elements, the generic forces of
creation, were they actually more
optimal and more conducive for longevity
than what we experience today? Well, I
imagine so because it probably be a lot
more abundant than it would be for the
amount of people we're supporting right
now. But yeah, exactly. No, not the
amount to forget today. about if the
creation is fresh created beautiful
created without any destructive forces
any harmful elements that means the
closer you are to creation the climate
is much more conducive right much more
productive for longevity but as the
earth decays as the general forces decay
and become more destructive then that
produces a climate and environment
which is less conducive for longevity.
So why would it shock you that people
are created to live
forever who then because of sin die
would live 900
800,000 what do you expect them to live
20 years because here wisdom of Solomon
chapter 1 12-6 watch read with me
brother read with me okay guys you
learning from the answers
right do not invite death wisdom Solomon
112:16 death by the air of your life or
bring on destruction by the works of
your hands. Because God did not make
death and he does not delight in the
death of the living, not just humans.
For he created all things, not just
humans, so that they may exist. Here's
the key. The generative forces of the
world are
wholesome. You got it? Yeah. So, they
would be a lot more stronger near the
time of Adam that kind of teared over
time. Well, here read that part. The
next line and there is no destructive
poison in them. Ah, okay. So, there
would have been less during that time.
Yep. And the men of Hades is not on
earth for righteousness is immortal. So
then why did they die? But the ungodly
by their words and deeds some death.
Considering him a friend, they pined
away and made a covenant with him
because they're fit to belong to his
company. So why would it shock you that
when God created the creation, it was
beautiful, conducive for everlasting
life, there were no destructive forces
to then lessen the lifespan because the
closer you are to creation, the better
it is, the more conducive it is. your
fruits, your vegetables are much
more healthier and more productive to
give you all the nutrients designed and
like what we eat today with pesticide
and all that garbage. Yeah. So why would
it be shocking that they live longer
when they were supposed to not die at
all? There's only go here,
brotherham,
brother. Wisdom 223 to 24. You guys got
your
answer? All right. For God created us
for incorruption, made us in the image
of his own eternity. He didn't make us
to die. But through the devil's envy,
death entered the world and those who
belong to his company experience it. So
why would I shock
you? I guess not. I mean, thinking about
it more like that helps a lot. But when
I was reading it had said that uh the
best way to conceptualize it is that
it's to conceptualize the great
antiquity of man. In other words, that
it be simply a literary technique used
to assert the remarkable age of the
human race itself is what the Ignatius
Study Bible says. But well, it's all
right. They're not infallible. I'm more
infallible. No, no. I was just wondering
just because You know what I think I got
to do, brother? I think I'm gonna have
to write a Bible commentary. What do you
think? Yeah. You think so? How long you
think that would take you, though? Uh,
that'll take me
about
maybe who knows, 20 years. But, uh,
maybe. Yeah. Uh, hopefully, I'd like to
see that. I wouldn't mind buying one of
those and seeing how that goes. If you
only buy one, then I'm not gonna make
you out to buy 10. Okay. Well, maybe
two, but I don't know. Is it gonna be
bigger than this or is it going to be
about the same size? Well, if I write a
commentary, it's going to be like 20
volumes, brother. I think. But anyway,
but let me tell you something. How
long's it going to take? Okay. So, by
the way, like I said, Satan Nation Study
Bible, their notes are good. They're not
infallible. I'm more infallible than
them. But anyway, let me let me hope
that give you an answer because I want
to tell you an inside joke because we're
talking about time. Okay. man asked God.
Said, "God,
yeah, I want to know how you measure
time." All right. What you want to know?
Go ahead and
ask. In your sight, how long is a
million years? So, a
second? Really? A second? Yeah. All
right. Can I ask you another question,
God? Sure. Go ahead. While you're at
it, how much is a million dollars? A
penny? A
penny? God, can I ask for a favor? Of
course. I'm
gracious. God, can you give me a
penny? Sure. Wait a
second. That's a good I've heard that
one before. I'm watching, so I like that
one. If he waits a second, he'll be in
heaven. Yeah, exactly. Also, I was
wondering, um, last thing, I have my,
uh, catechism to go along with this guy.
I was wondering if there's any other
things you'd recommend as I go along my
Bible study that I did. Get you I've
been told the best catechism is the
Boston Catechism, and I got to get it.
Catechism. If someone wants to donate to
the ministry financially so I can buy
books because I I need to make sure my
support doesn't decrease. They tell me
the Boston Catechism is the best and I
want to get it. They go that's the best.
You don't get it. I'm gonna have to
explain. So get that one. Okay. Didn't
get it. Okay. And I'll probably be
coming back because I've I've listened
to the Bible but it was only NIV so I
didn't get the rest of the seven books
which I'm kind of upset about. So I'm
getting into that now but I'll probably
be back as I go along and read Oh yeah.
Yeah. The Baltimore. You see how stupid
I am? Thank you, brother. Why did I
Baltimore Catechism? Okay, see guys, I'm
old. I'm old, man. Okay, Baltimore. I
heard that's the best. That Thank you,
brother. I want to get that. So, yeah,
let me know if you have more questions
so when you come on, I'll shut down. All
right, brother. Okay. Well, thank you.
God bless. Have a good one.